So let's talk about corona virus deaths for
weeks, almost for two months.
The right and the anti science crowd were
telling us, don't worry, cases are up, but
deaths aren't going to go up.
And we would say, why not?
And they would come up with explanations like,
well, listen, you know, it's young people
now who are getting the virus.
Young people don't get very sick.
They don't go into the hospital.
They don't die.
So even though cases are spiking starting
in mid-June, we're not going to see a spike
in deaths.
Some others would say it's a less serious
strain.
Now, the virus is mutated and it's far less
serious now.
Others said we're better at treating it.
Deaths won't go up.
We've got, you know, Hydroxy and Rham Desi
vier and we're just not going to see that
death spike because we're better at treating
it.
Well, for the like the tenth time in the last
month, we again have set a 30 to 60 day new
high water mark in terms of deaths.
And yesterday, fourteen hundred eighty five
people died of Corona virus, 14, 85.
That's half a 9/11 in a single day.
This is the most deaths yesterday since May
27.
There are about 64 days.
We are quickly losing all the progress that
was made during April and early May.
We're back at the May 27 death number.
If you look at the brown line on the graph
that we have up on the screen, that's the
seven day moving average.
So sometimes looking at individual days can
be less than a complete picture because we
tend to get less reporting on the weekends.
So if you look at a seven day average, you
can see that the seven day moving average
of deaths has been climbing since right around
the Fourth of July holiday here in the United
States.
That should have been a signal that things.
Weren't being done correctly, it has now been
almost a month since then.
As you probably know by now, deaths are a
lagging indicator to cases.
So even if we believe that cases started to
flatten on July 16th.
Now, many of us don't believe that because
that's the day on which reporting from hospitals
shifted from going to the CDC, instead going
to Trump's Department of Health and Human
Services.
But if you believe that case has started to
flatten on July 16th, then that means we are
still weeks from the peak in terms of single
day deaths.
And that means that 10 or 14 days from now,
the daily death toll could be once again tragic.
It could get to a 9/11 every day or just short
of it.
Now, as you know, as it's almost become apocryphal
at this point, but I've been saying Massachusetts
has handled the virus quite well.
But if you're all in the same pool and someone's
peeing in the deep end and you're in the shallow
end, eventually you're going to get some of
that pee in the shallow end.
If you understand what I'm saying, eventually
it's going to reach you.
We're all in the same pool.
And even here in Massachusetts, it's a slow
uptick, but there is an uptick.
And it started in mid-July.
We had, you know, 175, 200 cases a day for
weeks.
We're now more regularly getting 300, 325
cases a day.
And we're about to see, is it 50000, is it
100000, 150000 college students flying in
over the next four weeks to start college
and add to that that we're about to get hit
with the flu season in the United States.
I'm seeing CBS and Walgreens advertising flu
shots.
I'm going to get mine very soon.
This could be ramping up to arguably the worst
or most difficult fall in the United States
from a public health standpoint.
I will just say in a very long time, does
it go all the way back to 1918 and the flu?
I'm not sure.
But certainly in decades, people just aren't
listening.
Much of the world did handle this.
This was not the only way that it could have
gone the trajectory in the United States.
I hate that it has become political, but because
Donald Trump did fail us.
He has to suffer the consequences.
He has to be removed in November.
I don't even need a president that will do
anything that special.
We just need one that will do.
I was just interviewed actually on a New Zealand
program, and we'll be posting that very soon
to YouTube and Facebook.
Jacinda Ardern in New Zealand.
She didn't bring any unique medical knowledge.
She just realized that she shouldn't pretend
to know things she doesn't know.
She's going to defer to the doctors and let
the doctors lead the way with her support.
That's all I need a president to do.
But we are now back where we were months ago.
We're sort of starting from scratch in a sense.
There are discussions about needing a full
lockdown reset to get things under control.
I don't think there's any political appetite
for that at this point in time.
And think about all of the people who stayed
home for months, sacrificed financially, sacrificed,
you know, psychologically and emotionally
to flatten the curve.
We're back to where we were back then.
And we are still up against mass evictions,
growing unemployment.
Consider the disrespect, by the way, to the
health care workers.
Remember, they're heroes.
We appreciate them.
Right?
Well, then why isn't everybody wearing a mask?
How is it respectful to health care workers
to walk around with no mask and to have indoor
dining and have casinos open in movie theaters?
We haven't done the right thing for them as
much as for the victims of the virus.
It's disgusting.
It's tragic.
And the next three months, it could be really
bad.
It could be really, really bad.
And I want to hear what's going on in your
state.
I am on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know how you see it.
Let me know what's taking place.